[Music]
you know life is about choices
mr ruggs made a choice
and the difficulty i have is there's so
many alternatives
sharp words this morning from district
attorney steve wolfson following former
raider henry ruggs's appearance in court
this morning we thank you for joining us
here at noon i'm heather mills 8 news
now following the very latest
information on the deadly crash
involving now former raiders wide
receiver henry ruggs iii
the i-team was the first to report rux's
blood alcohol content was twice the
legal limit he was driving
156 miles an hour on rainbow near spring
valley parkway right before that crash a
judge set bail this morning in our
hector mejia joining us now live outside
clark county detention center where
ruggs remains at this hour
hey there well the state had asked for
bail to be set at 1 million dollars rugs
hired high profile attorneys and the
judge instead granted their request for
bail to be set at 150 thousand dollars
if that's posted rugs will get to walk
out of the clark county detention center
for now with the following conditions
electronic monitoring ordered not to
drive drink alcohol or take other
controlled substances plus surrender his
passport
wearing a neck brace nfl star henry
ruggs was wheeled into court wednesday
morning accused of driving 156 miles an
hour on rainbow crashing his corvette
into another car 23-year-old tina tinter
and her dog died her rat 4 burst into
flames tinter's family was in the
courtroom the families torn apart
mourning their loss they're grieving
they're mad the raiders dropped rugs
from the team he currently faces two
counts of felony dui and reckless
driving resulting in death if convicted
prison time would be between 2 and 46
years prosecutors are considering
additional charges saying he was
illegally in possession of a loaded gun
rugs's girlfriend was also injured
argumentative and uncooperative with
both police and medical workers high
profile attorney david chestnut he has
consistently followed rules and
regulations
he played for a major division one
national championship football team
followed all the roles and was an
excellent teammate and player district
attorney steve olson said that in his 41
years in las vegas he's never seen a
case involving speeds over 150 miles an
hour regardless of speed i asked him if
there's anything lawmakers can do to
prevent felony dui cases months ago we
filed murder charges in a case very
similar to this
where there was excessive and reckless
driving
but the nevada supreme court said that
was inappropriate and we accept that
but there is the next legislative
session
and wolfson said lawmakers should really
consider increasing the punishment
meanwhile ruggs is due back in court
november 10th that is when he will be
formally charged reporting outside the
clark county detention center in
downtown hector mejia live local now